if you can't feel the emotion of your
future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
my relationship hat when i find mr right
then i'm going to feel love waiting for
the outer environment to change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness
but they forgot that they create reality
in other words when it finally appears
that i'm going to feel love that's
that's cause and effect we're waiting
for something to happen if you're
feeling the lack and the emptiness
then you're keeping your relationship at
arm's length because you don't have the
magnetic field to draw to you
so the emotions that come from these
energy centers the lower energy centers
in our body do have
frequencies there's chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field
and you could actually crack this thing
open
and practice
getting so present in the moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past you can find that
sweet spot of the generous present
moment the familiar past is the known
emotionally the predictable future is
the habituation of autopilot being
unconscious in programs those are both
knowns there's only one place where the
unknown exists that's the present moment
so if you could work with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to work with your
heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion
and you feel love your body's so
objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future in the present moment and
your body now is beginning to change
you are beginning to change your biology
to reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response
memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future
instead of remembering your past if
you're truly in the present moment and
you know exactly what you want
and you begin to teach your body emotion
start practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough yeah
whatever that is
that's called the default mode it
suppresses the default mode network and
the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the heart is the
creative center we got to put our heart
into our future it better be open and
activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide signals another chemical
called endothelial derived relaxing
factor and just like when your sexual
organs get filled with blood because
you're aroused the same thing happens
here as it would happen somewhere else
and literally the arteries in the heart
and lungs engorge and now your heart
feels full and it's thumping in order
and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens and it's beating in rhythm the
heart produces an external magnetic
field up to three meters wide now you're
in survival you're drawing from the
field and turning into chemistry when
you get energy in the heart it's causing
a change in the brain
and all of a sudden it's resetting the
baseline for trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation
and now that that energy is frequency
and frequency carries information and
you can lay the thought of your new
relationship
on that energy life is a series of
changes those of us who are rigid and
inflexible in our thinking often snap
when the winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences
i am unlimited in my own ability to
create the good in my life life mirrors
my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love
light and joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have and i know
fresh new experiences are always ahead
of me i greet the new with open arms i
trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous
if your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success i know i can be as successful as
i make my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
[Music]
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well someone said
to us one day when we were trying to get
them to focus upon positive things and
we sort of laid out a list of positive
things that she might think about and
she said oh abraham i don't want those
i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain
the pattern of thought that you have a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others sometimes it
came because of something that you
observed and then talked about and then
remembered and then attracted again and
then talked about it and then remembered
and then attracted again in other words
life is very interesting here isn't it
because you can't talk about anything
for very long before it begins to
replicate itself in your life experience
and it's what makes you develop your
patterns of what you call truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure
and then i pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it this
gathering we're calling it the art of
allowing but what it really means is the
art of telling a different story the art
of telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story
with your words with your observations
with your expectations with your
vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are the things in your life that are not
as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better until you are aware of what you
are choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was of
famous physicists in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is
immaterial it's mental
and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part and the reality
about it why is that and so important as
uh sad vijay had just mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right
i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around and it
basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world and then i give you the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind i say
what's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh i wish i had this and
i desire that and these are the things i
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 of the day
because we are thinking 95 of the day
our behavior is now controlled by the
subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have
and then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator of your life and
when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people i use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed when you were a little baby
this is the way it was go just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you were
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something that
something different and what we want to
do is program in positive information
and eliminate the negative
i'm going to show you how to do that
a law of attraction you attract
according to the vibration you're in
this thing we live in is a molecular
structure your body is a massive energy
you know if you put your body in front
of an infrared television camera in a
completely dark room your whole being
would be nothing but a glistening
radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm and get you on that
frequency tantra means the technology
technology means
when those times when we did not have
any external instruments of technology
we realized the highest grade of
technologies here
and to exercise this
in many different ways
now
if we want to see outside that door
we need a periscope
now somebody found a way to look beyond
without a periscope
using your mind
beyond the realm of your body right now
mind is functioning within the realm of
your body you want to use it there
it is possible to do that it's not not
possible
it's just that
all kinds of wild and observed things
are believed if you trim those things
in many ways
knowingly or unknowingly many of you are
using this
you create what you want in the world
when you really want it
in a way it's simply your focus which
makes those things happen
maybe it is not as
tangible
as uh it's in a cinema
but
every one of you to some extent you're
doing isn't it
how effectively do you do it
depends on
there are many things if i say things
that happen around me
they're too fairy talish
i wouldn't believe such nonsense if
anybody told me so i won't tell you
because i don't want you to believe or
disbelieve those things but every day
people around me witness things which
they think is nothing short of a miracle
but there's no miracle
life is a big miracle
are you a part of it or are you out of
it that's a big question question is are
you consciously in it
or are you out of it that's a big
question
if you're in it
you're see if you use any thought
this is uh well he was asking how do we
do it in the beginning
suppose you generate a thought
have you noticed this suppose you
generate a thought
and then you invest your emotion in this
thought suddenly this thought becomes
boom
huh
yes or no
right now i generate a thought oh she's
such a wonderful person
but now i invest my emotion into the
thought now suddenly
you are not just another person to me
you are something else to me
is it reality or no
just because you invested your emotion
into your thought
now there is a next thing
if you invest your life energies into it
consciously
suddenly this will become something else
altogether
suddenly you become like
life is a play
it's no more a struggle
because
miracles are always happening you put a
little seed it becomes a tree he eats a
noodle he becomes a man
i'm saying this is happening to
it's happening all the time just see you
put filth into the root just see it
becomes fragrance
is it is this not miracles and miracles
all over the place
the question is only
are you consciously a part of this
miraculous creation
or are you
stuck in your own logic and outside this
miracle
that's all the big differences
many people come to me and say i want to
be a millionaire i i and there's a great
song about i'm going to be a millionaire
and they read things like the secret
which says if you want to be a
millionaire just just wish it and it
will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out and make
a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help
the more reasons you will have to become
and stay a millionaire
and here's the third thing and this is
so important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
with my sofa and manifest millions if
you want a job you go out and look for a
job if you want a new home you go out
and visit new homes you want a partner
you better go out and put yourself in
front of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hairdryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way
it's not about shall i invent something
i don't have an inventive mind i'm not
creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel and show it to other people who
also want to make money why wouldn't you
want to make money you can do great
things for others when you make money
but they don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and
chant on shanti and money will fall from
the heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to bring what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i just
manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day
meeting deadlines i travel all over the
world through time zones giving talks
and sometimes that's tiring i plan out
my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire and not have to change
anything or do anything or work hard you
will probably never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said somebody
always remembered do not die with your
music still inside and i thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson read felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire money is the exchange of
values
in fact the way a society spends
money
is uh
a clue
to their values
so right now most uh
wealthy nations and even some unwealthy
nations poor nations are spending money
on weapons on mechanized death
on drugs
on alcohol
on gambling
on sleazy stuff
and that only represents the collective
consciousness of
bad money bad karma
and
therefore
stay away
from
any
way that
generates money through harm
and this is what
the great teacher of all time
the buddha he said
right livelihood
so right livelihood is that kind of
livelihood
that
creates
joy in the world that
increases abundance in the world
increases
and improves the quality of life in the
world
okay
understand that when you're exchanging
money you're exchanging values
there's a clear separation between
awareness and the mind we're not the
mind rather we're awareness moving
through different areas of the mind
right so this is the most important
thing that i can share with you and this
is really the core
uh it is the foundation of everything
that i do teach
so once you realize that you're not the
mind but rather that you that rather
that your awareness moving through
different areas of mind you can control
where your awareness goes
and now i want to bring your attention
to another point this is a saying that
my guru said many many decades ago where
awareness goes energy flows right and
you've heard me share this many times as
well online
so once you know that you're not the
mind rather than your awareness and if
you can control where your awareness
goes you can control where your energy
is flowing now let's look at energy
energy is like water right whatever it
is your water will start to grow
energy works the same thing in the same
way too whatever it is you put energy
into will start to manifest in your life
so if you put energy into something
negative it'll grow and manifest in your
life you put energy into something
positive it'll grow and manifest in your
life one thing you want to do is move
your awareness there as you move your
awareness to those goals that's where
your energy is flowing and as your
energy flows there you they start to
manifest in your life but one of the
things you want to do is to be mindful
and be very conscious of where you're
spending your energy you only have so
much energy each day right
so you want to really assess your life
and look at the people and things in
your life and say okay i've only got
this much energy how can i take this
finite amount of energy that i have
and proportionately divide it into these
people and things
in my life that i care about so that i
can start to manifest them remember what
manifests in your life is
proportionately
is in proportion to what how much energy
that you're actually investing into
something so if you want something to
manifest in your life put energy into it
how do you put your energy into it you
move your awareness to that thing and
when you move your awareness there where
awareness goes energy flows
and that thing starts to manifest in
your life three things to keep in mind
purpose
focus simplify have a clear purpose
clear goals
focus on those things right focus on
those purposes and those goals
throughout the year always bring your
awareness back to them and simplify your
life simplify your life to the most
important people and the most important
things in your life so that you can take
the finite amount of energy
that you have and invest it into those
people and things into your into your
goals to manifest what you want to
manifest now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated the science says you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through on your goals that's not good
enough no not for you believe nation we
got to do something but when you write
it down and you create a specific plan
of action for the next week that number
jumps to 91 chance of you following
through and when you commit to somebody
else like leaving a comment on this
video it jumps to 95 you need to follow
through on your goals so what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your specific plan of action for the
next week put it down in the comments
below so i can celebrate you your energy
dictates your results think about it
when you have felt positive motivated
energized ready to go courageous bold
you show up differently right you show
up differently than when you're feeling
depressed that it's not going to work
out
the negative self-talk someone like you
can't do it you're not getting any
momentum you're not getting the results
like think about your own mental state
when you are
[Music]
trying to accomplish a goal
and the difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
so it's all about changing your energy
states
i think there's a misconception that
people who are high achievers wake up
and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes
come on
[Music]
let's go take on the day i'm so excited
right that's not how i woke up today i
woke up it was dark outside it's snowing
as you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it she's
driving through the the snow storm it's
dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
going to be i wake up but i'm tired and
i'm like why is it so dark outside why
we have the snowstorm uh you know i'm
thinking about the call i had yesterday
with brendon burchard on zoom and he's
showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up
like they're a superhuman and extra
motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so there's there's two
things that i want you to start thinking
about how do you do it right like okay
great evan how do i do it how do i
actually change my energy how do i get
it so that i am feeling powerful bold
motivated confident excited on a daily
basis because it is possible and because
you know how great you feel and you know
the results that you get when you're
feeling that way
so two things that i want you to keep in
mind the first one is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist
it's hashtag believe all caps on my main
channel you can go find it that's the
music i listen to every day that may not
be the thing that gets you fired up but
it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them
it just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be not
in your head you might be tapping your
foot but there are some songs that come
on that make you want to move it can't
just be the same song every day because
then you're going to get sick of it and
bored of it but you make a playlist of
the different music that when it comes
on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel
so when you're sad and low and depressed
or upset you put on music that makes you
feel
reinforced and you're sad and low and
depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music for how
you currently feel it keeps you where
you are where what you want to do is use
music to shift your state so when you're
feeling not so motivated when you're
feeling tired when you're feeling low
you put on music that gets you up and
what's going to happen you're going to
feel a little bit more up so putting
that as a part of your daily routine
daily daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
routine it matters it makes a difference
if you if you started your day with
music that would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will look
different your months will look
different and the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do in step number one is we do on a
daily basis in the morning step number
two is when we have something that
we come across
that
makes us feel
less confident that makes us feel scared
that is a big opportunity that makes us
question ourselves doubt ourselves
when you look at your calendar you look
at your emails you look at the results
and you've seen them you're not where
you want to be
the tendency is to beat ourselves up the
tendency is to play scared the tendency
is to act small the tendency is to
procrastinate and go do something else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy
is now the reason why we're staying
where we are so how do we shift our
energy
in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard that if it's scary
that it's difficult you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it you're gonna show up
you're gonna do it because you do
difficult things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking
over-procrastinating uh and being overly
scared
if you want to learn the billionaire
mindset that can make you rich check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there the problem that is
obvious to you may not necessarily be
the solution that exists in that problem
when you come up with a goal that this
is what you set out to do